-Tariq, we're about to
play charades,
but first we're gonna
need some more players.
Joining my team, she stars in
one of the biggest shows on TV.
Please welcome Sydney Sweeney!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Indistinct conversation ]
-I'm sorry.
-We're on the same team.
But this is interesting. Sydney,
I'm so happy you're here,
but you were telling me
backstage
you've never played charades
before.
-I've never played.
And he was like,
"I hope I'm not on your team."
-No, I didn't say that!
-Yes, you did!
-I kind of did.
But I didn't mean it.
Now we're on the same team.
Come on. We got this...
-We got this.
-Let's do it. Let's crush.
Joining Tariq's team,
you can see him this Friday
in "Dr. Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness."
Please welcome
Benedict Cumberbatch!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh!
Now, now! Come on.
Good to see you, bud.
As always.
-How are you?
[ Indistinct conversation ]
-I know, I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Now, you all know
how to play charades.
We're going to do four rounds.
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
Sydney, I'll make this easy.
Alright. Tariq, Benedict,
you guys can sit here.
-Okay.
-Sydney, you can sit here.
-We got this. We got this.
-Here's the fun thing.
We didn't even really talk
last night.
Even though we were
at the same Met Gala,
so we saved up, and now we're
not going to talk now, either.
-We're on the same --
-Here we go.
What number do you think?
[ Audience shouting ]
Okay. Here we go.
-Okay.
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. We got this.
-Good.
We have this, okay?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
This is not a good start.
-No, it is. We have this.
Ready?
-Okay.
-Sydney, here we go.
-Play -- House -- Play.
[ Laughter ]
-This isn't even the clue.
This means TV.
-Okay. Sorry.
-Yeah. Alright.
-TV.
-Yeah.
-One word.
First word. "Euphoria"?
-Yeah!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how we do it.
That's how we do it.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Wow. Wow.
-We got something right there.
-That was awesome.
-So, if you get "Dr. Strange,"
that would be very interesting.
No. Benedict, you're up.
-I'm up?
-Let's have our guests go first.
-Okay. Great. Great.
-You good with that?
-Yeah.
The way you did. Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience shouting ]
-Go six. Go six.
-Six. Very good.
Mm-hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright.
[ Inhales sharply ] Uh...
-You guys work together before?
-Here we go.
-Oh, wow. Look at this.
-Do we give hints?
-Okay. Long word.
[ Laughter ]
Is that a -- Okay. TV show.
-Oh, TV show.
-Three words. First word.
T -- The.
Second word.
"The Walking Dead"?
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-I'm sorry.
-We're in the zone.
We're dialed in, buddy.
-What episode of "Walking Dead"
do they walk like this?
[ Laughter ]
That is not fair at all.
Sydney -- Oh, my gosh.
No spoilers. I haven't seen
the end of this season.
Sydney, whenever you're ready,
pick a number.
That was good.
-Okay.
[ Audience shouting ]
Five?
-I'm not looking.
I'm not looking. Here we go.
-[ Gasps ] I got this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That wasn't it.
-You have this, right? Yeah.
I like the confidence.
-Okay.
What type of format is it?
It's a movie!
-Yeah.
-It has four words.
Ooh. Uh, witch?
[ Laughter ]
Like a sorceress?
Woman? Girl?
Beautiful -- Girl. Beauty.
"Beauty and the Beast."
-Yes! Whoo!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-We can go on the road!
-Good luck!
-We should go on the road!
-Oh, my goodness!
-I thought you were doing,
like, a sorceress --
-No.
-Wow. We're going to go on
the road with charades here.
-That was impressive.
-That was not bad.
It was impressive.
-Alright.
-Alright. Alright.
-Yes, yes. Big, big money.
-Ten! Ten!
[ Audience shouting ]
Ten!
-Ten!
-One!
-Okay, okay.
Ooh. This one's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you ready?
-You're not doing it to me, man.
-TV.
-Uh -- Oh.
-Film.
-Oh, no.
-"Dr. Strange.
In the Multiverse of Madness."
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-[ Laughs ]
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-What are these clues?!
What's going on? The next one's
"Tonight Show," yeah.
Alright, alright.
This is a showdown round, okay?
Shouldn't be that easy.
But, Sydney, I think
you should give clues.
And, Benedict,
I think you should give clues.
And Tariq and I will guess,
okay?
You both give clues
of the same number.
Whoever team gets this first
wins 10,000 points
and wins the whole thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, you guys go.
-Alright.
-Which one should we go?
-I don't know.
Should we start at the top?
-Which one?
-Should we start at number 1?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Number one.
-Do one. One.
-I don't know who said three.
There is no three.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God. Okay.
-Wait. She's going already.
Here we go. Ready?
-It's a song.
-Song.
-Five words.
-Four words. Down.
-Jimmy and Tariq:
"Drop It Like It's Hot!"
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-No, no, no! Judges!
-Replay.
-I want an instant replay!
Right now! Who did it?
Do you think Tariq? Or me?
Tariq?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Me?
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
Let's play it back right now.
I really want to know
who won this. Come on!
-"Drop It Like It's Hot!"
[ Bell dinging ]
I was done.
I was already finished saying it
when you were still
on "Like It's."
"Drop It Like It's Hot."
"Like It's Hot."
-The judges say Tariq Trotter
is the champion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our thanks
to Benedict Cumberbatch
and Tariq Trotter, the winners.
Sydney Sweeney, my partner,
was great.
We're talking to Benedict
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
We had that!
That was a good clue!
[ Indistinct conversation ]